es una función que describe una sucesión
aritmética aquí están los primeros
términos de la sucesión entonces vemos
que el primer término es 4 el segundo
término es tres y cuatro quintos el
tercer término es tres y tres quintos el
cuarto término es tres y dos quintos
encuentra los valores de los parámetros
faltantes a ive en la siguiente
definición recursiva de la sucesión muy
bien entonces vemos que el enésimo
término será igual a 100 es igual a 1 y
será igual a gdn menos 1 más b si él es
mayor que 1 entonces bueno como siempre
te invito a que pongas pausa al vídeo y
que intentes averiguar cuáles son los
valores de aire de ahora vamos a
intentarlo el valor de a sale de
inmediato observa los siguientes 100 es
igual a 1 el primer término cuando n es
igual a 1 es 4 por lo tanto a es igual
lo podemos escribir como gdn
es igual a 4 si n es igual a 1
ahora pensemos en la segunda línea la
cual bueno me resulta bastante
interesante dice lo siguiente dice que
será igual al término previo
cdn menos uno esto significa que el
término n menos uno más b te dará el
enésimo término pensemos en qué está
pasando con esta sucesión aritmética
cuando pasó del primer término al
segundo término que he hecho parece que
he restado un quinto entonces menos un
quinto
y como esta es una sucesión en genética
debo restar la misma cantidad cada vez
entonces restó un quinto y nuevamente
resto un quinto
una manera de pensar lo es si avanzamos
al revés
podríamos decir por ejemplo que g de 4
es igual a g de 3 menos un quinto
g de 3 es esto le resta es un quinto y
obtienes gr4 también puedo describirlo
como g de 4
es igual a g de 41
- un quinto
y si lo ves de esta forma puedes ver que
si quiero encontrar el enésimo término
será el n menos un término más menos un
quinto por lo tanto b es igual a menos
un quinto estoy intentando encontrar el
cuarto término si em es igual a 4 no voy
a poder usar el primer caso porque este
caso es para n igual a 1 y 4 es mayor
que 1 así que si n es igual a 4 uso el
segundo caso baja porque n igual a 44 es
mayor que 1 entonces usamos el segundo
caso y entonces será gdn menos 1 que
será igual a g de 3 menos un quinto por
lo tanto podemos decir que gdn será
igual a cdn menos uno menos un quinto
si n es mayor que 1 así que los valores
son para tenemos que es igual a 4 y b es
igual a menos un quinto